[Music]
and so I feel what I'm about to ask you
but I'm curious myself
Jodie wants to know Kat who is the
better kisser Dahmer Alberto I'm not
answer this question what I it's I can't
suspect it I'll get to it I have J v on
that's why depends on I'm sorry um
they're both amazing I can tell you that
well and of course because you don't
want to upset the one and only Sarah
Hyland who is dating dumb in real life
and she's gonna be on the show yeah they
just announced that we've been keeping
that so secret for so long so hard how
long have you been keeping this a secret
a long time really really long time
yeah but we've all been I'm really proud
of us because we were open so excited
about it it's been really hard to keep
secret um but you know she's been a part
of this family since day one
and so having her on the show was only a
fit you know it was only natural but
that's all I can say
can you cheese when we might see her
appear I don't think I can without
getting in trouble
can you maybe tease what she will be
playing absolutely not Nick I'm sorry
I'm sorry I want to tell you I really do
yeah but they'll kill me how about this
what was your reaction when you
discovered that she was gonna be coming
on in this role oh it's perfect there is
no other it's it's perfect you guys are
gonna be so happy I cannot wait for you
to see this
[Music]
you